the New York Times reports one of the  leaders of the me2 movement Italian  actress Asia Argento is now accused of  making a deal with a young actor who  said she sexually assaulted him Argento  is one of the women accusing Harvey  Weinstein of sexual assault she  reportedly arranged to pay Jimmy Bennett  three hundred and eighty thousand  dollars the payment was made after he  filed notice of intent to sue accusing  her of sexually assaulting him in a  California hotel room years earlier he  says he was only two months past his  17th birthday the age of consent in  California is 18 she was 37 at the time  Argento claims Weinstein rape her at the  Cannes Film Festival when she was 21 we  reached out to our Gento for comment but  have not heard back bennett declined to  comment